yo
good morning everybody good evening if
you're in another part of the world
my name is clinton jones i am the
punisher
and we're here today to talk about
product photography and how to texture
for product photography as well as more
importantly how to light for product
photography because
it can be very tricky to get a you know
that nice professional
look um you know a lot of people got a
studio
they got a bunch of big lights um and
it's expensive you know and they're
sitting there
tinkering and toying with their lights
and everything to get the perfect shine
the perfect reflections but we're going
to do that
in cg today i'm specifically in cinema
4d
but if you guys are in blender or 3ds
max or maya or whatever
you guys can do it just the same it's
we're just talking textures
and lights in theory and we're gonna
we're gonna make it easy
we're gonna dive into it it's gonna be
really fun we're gonna get a couple
different looks
out of this um that is my goal
for today with you guys is to get a
couple different looks
um and do some fun experimenting
and use some some of my favorite tools
and plugins
to make it easy for you guys i want to
show you some cool stuff
so yeah this is an exciting episode a
very very exciting
episode so not only are we going to
learn how to texture and light
this camera um we are going to
one i'm going to announce the winners i
did a
contest like a random raffle um
with pny and nvidia and we're giving
away
graphics cards ssds flash drives that
kind of stuff
and i'm gonna you know go over the
i believe there's the five or six
winners that i'm going to announce here
um who are going to win some really cool
stuff so i'm going to announce that
very very soon um and then i am going to
talk about our wonderful sponsor today
which i am
god i am so excited i am so excited
um but before i do that i just want to
say hey to you guys in the chat here
it's a live stream so it wouldn't be you
know it wouldn't make sense if i didn't
chat it up with y'all what's going on
thank you for joining thanks for being
here
on a saturday um good times very good
times
yeah i mean so i'm using octane um it's
my uh
my renderer of choice i know some of you
guys use
redshift or arnold but i am purely
in octane today
it's a good time i learned from david
ariev um
the man the myth the legend octane jesus
they call him
uh no this camera's not textured but
we're gonna texture it together we're
gonna talk about uh the details of
texturing how to get it right how to
look
how to make it look really nice tom
thanks for the super chat i appreciate
your brother
we'll just let every everyone buddy roll
on in here this morning
very exciting very exciting
yeah i mean i'm glad you guys enjoyed
the vfx artist react this week
it's always fun talking about vfx
hanging out with sam and nico and ren
it's a good time
what's up y'all what is up what is going
on
yeah the andrew kramer episode we filmed
with andrew kramer
uh this week actually and i got to sit
down with him and have a have a good
chat and
we got real technical and everything and
asked some good questions nico asked a
lot of good questions
uh mr visual he asks is the philosophy
of lighting
the same for motion shots too um
absolutely yeah absolutely usually you
see okay what's the camera seeing here's
my angle here's my shot this is what
it's looking like alright so within the
bounds of what i just saw whether it's a
still
shot or whether it is a moving shot
that's my playground that's what i have
to work with
so i need to hide the lights and place
the lights in a strategic position
um you know to either a make them look
natural
like roger deakins is one of my favorite
dps and he makes everything look so
natural
i love that um you also have i don't
know who shoots
david fincher's stuff but his stuff
looks very natural
and that there's a there's a trick to
making things look very natural
in our case we're talking product
photography so if i were to just pull
up a quick google search for product
photography you'll see here that it's
very stylized
it can be very colorful it can be very
high key this is very bright you know
high key lighting
or you can have something a bit more
dramatic like you know this watch ad
right here
where you know you really are trying to
catch the shine
off the edge of this watch and we're
going to be texturing you know this
camera in cinema 4d
so there's a lot of metal to this and i
actually do want to texture this thing
in a very specific way i want to texture
it so that it appears to look
like an old school film camera versus an
ace
the sony a7r ii or something um so i
think that could be a fun spin on it
like if
if sony put out like the classic you
know camera style
look i think that'd be cool so why not
you know we're in 3d so
we can do whatever the heck we want
all righty all righty now we got a good
number of people in here
um what's up everybody when will you
know that next week's challenge it's
gonna be the end of the stream once i
get through the whole lesson
at the very end of the stream i
announced the winners of the
weekly challenge which was neon this
week and then i'll announce the new
challenge
for this week but thank you guys for
joining um
let's uh let's get into it
so i want to tell you guys a story here
a couple years ago two or three years
ago i didn't know
jack about cinema 4d i didn't know
anything about 3d uh well that's not
true
um i i took a long break from cinema 4d
and i actually ended up coming back to
c4d i love this program so much
and i found a website called grayscale
gorilla and they are the sponsor of
today's video so shout outs
to grayscale gorilla right so this is
another
another uh another company that um
i have the pleasure of knowing uh nick
and chad over at grayscale
and they are very nice very kind people
um and it's really cool it's really
surreal because i again
use their product way before they came
to me as a sponsor
and i couldn't be more excited about
about doing this with them today so
basically before i knew cinema
i started watching grayscale gorilla
tutorials right
and you know i was watching videos on
the airplane when i was flying
on different productions with corridor
or flying back home for
christmas i'd be watching grayscale
gorilla
tutorials and if it wasn't for that
you know i would do this for about you
know a week or two or three
just watching these tutorials not
knowing anything really about c4d
um and then and then three weeks later i
was tasked with um
doing a pretty advanced cg shot for the
primitive technology videos at corridor
and if i hadn't watched those videos
over at greyskill i would not have been
able to complete the shot in time
so grayskill has a you know a very
nice spot in my heart if you guys don't
know what grayscale gorilla is
they are the number one largest
source of tutorials training
assets materials they basically have
everything for cinema 4d if you guys are
trying to learn cinema 4d
this is the place to go this is where i
learned how to do everything i'm doing
here in central 4d
it is where i learned how to do so
um and they are so generous and so kind
they actually hooked you guys up with
30 off of their new service it's called
grayscale gorilla plus boom
they got everything for you guys here
basically
like i said they have the training they
have the products they have the plugins
they have the materials
and it's all in one spot for you guys
and if you use clint 30 the promo code
clint 30 you guys
will get 30 percent off your annual
um subscription to grayscale gorilla
plus which is a huge deal you're saving
you're saving a ton of money like
honestly it's a legit deal
um but yeah get you know give them a
shot check it out
like again i i've learned
so much from these guys this good old
nick right there
you know they got a whole bunch of good
stuff
um and we're going to get into it you
know i'm going to talk about their new
technology material pack that they just
released
um it's absolutely incredible and it
makes texturing things
really easy and we'll get into it i want
to show you guys
how it's used here but they got
materials they got training they got
plug-ins
um so yeah i'm just
such a freaking huge fan of these guys
um and i'm so happy with how far they've
come at this point
um so if if you guys are using cinema 4d
definitely go over to grayscale
check them out use the promo code it's
a really really really nice deal it'll
help you guys out
it'll teach you how to use cinema 4d on
your own time
watch it on the airplane watch it over
christmas break
it'll it'll be amazing i promise you
guys will have a good time
but their tech products right here this
is their new uh tutorial pack that i'll
be diving into
um and they actually came out with a new
hub
so you can actually open it up here drag
and drop stuff in
they got textures too i know chad was
making these surface imperfections by
hand
um you know doing his thing absolutely
incredible
um so next year you know they're
dropping all of their products in the
plus
so if you guys are subscribed to plus
you guys are going to have literally
every product that they make
at your disposal if you're a plus
member so everything is going to plus
early next year you guys are getting the
hdris
hdri link um
you'll have literally everything and
everything they put out in the future
will be on grayscale gorilla the plus
service um so don't miss out guys it's a
good time
uh my boy david arya of octane jesus
himself
uh has got a really fun getting started
with octane tutorial
um uh course right here it's amazing
um i've watched it this is how i learned
how to do x particles
is through grayscale gorilla they have a
course on topography
or topology rather and also they do have
a course on a tech lighting breakdown
which is what we're getting into today
but if you guys want to take a deeper
dive
um grace gorilla is the place to do so
so thank you guys thank you
um to grayscale you know these guys are
freaking amazing i love them so much
they've taught me so much so use that
promo code right
jump in with me let's learn together i'm
still learning from them and i'll be
learning from them for
as long as i'm using c4d y'all
very exciting very exciting tom dude
thank you thank you for that super chat
that is very generous of you
i appreciate it man um heck yeah
absolutely
all right i don't think i missed
anything um
if i did i'm sure we'll get into it here
because we're gonna be using
uh their you know their new tech product
tech materials
to texture this camera here and
i'll show you how cool it it it is and
how easy it is
to use all right so
um
i'm gonna grab a cookie and then we're
gonna jump in we're gonna start
texturing this thing right
with the grayscale gorillas new tech
textures they're amazing
peter yes peter i will use an hdri
certainly mm-hmm
it's a pretty darn good cookie right
there
i don't have any milk but i don't need
any cause i got some water right here
all right my friends let's do this
jump in for a little bit and i'm gonna
announce the winners of the raffle
but let's jump in let's open up that
grayscale gorilla plus library
and see what we got so they're tech
products
such an awesome service you guys got
like braided cables brushed aluminum
brushed steel
camera paint um
i mean i'm just gonna drag one of these
out
zoom on up in here and see
what it's doing for us they even have
like camera grip
too it's amazing so you get that really
nice
just that subtle texture and then we can
take it down just a little bit
so
yikes oh i put on the wrong thing
where are we now bam
here we go
so we'll like tile it multiple times
it's just a very very subtle
kind of a camera plastic which is
amazing
but it's not the it's not what we're
we're going for right now like i said
i'm gonna try and replicate the old film
camera look
on this new dslr and then we're gonna
light it and make it look really sick
i think it's gonna be awesome
all right so
let's see what we got let's see what
we got now i want to find
like a very rough metal
like this right here that i'm seeing
over the top of this thing i think
that's our main
it's like our main texture and there's
also this like uh
you know grippy bumpy texture
that's around the outside of this camera
it makes up most of the camera so those
are the two
main materials that we're going to try
and look for with uh
the grayscale gorilla plus library here
under tech products
let's see here so they actually have
camera grip let's see if there's
anything metal i'm going to start with
the metal
there's a headphone connector maybe
we'll we'll try that i'm just dragging
these out
um metallic plastic that could certainly
work
sandblasted aluminum give that a shot
all right let's try those three
and let's texture the crap out of this
thing all right so let's start with the
headphones
so that's very reflective and and by the
way i do have a small i have an hdri
wrapped around the scene right now it's
actually a studio hdri
also from grayscale gorilla and all that
stuff will be available in plus
early next year for you guys um full
access to their whole
their whole suite of products everything
will be in plus
so i'm using some of those right now
just to temporarily light the scene so i
can texture it
and then we'll really dive into the
lighting um
now i know that this top piece
um should be broken up
where are you
there we go all right so the body
i want the body to be
this kind of metallic
texture as well minus
minus these bits here which i'll do as a
black kind of plastic so let's see if we
can
find a black plastic in their new tech
materials
um they have plastic
pattern different patterns and stuff so
let's see if we can pull out one of
these guys
throw it on here
now the topology or the topography
of this camera is not
the best
so i'm about to get in here and select
these polygons
and let's just see
what this looks like
so it's very subtle but it has a nice
like bumpy texture to it that i
think will go the extra mile
with this kind of stuff when you're
doing tech products
or not just tech products when you're
doing products in general when you're
doing product photography
and you're texturing this stuff you
really want it to feel as real as
possible so it's these small little bump
elements like this that
make it go and feel real
and it goes above and beyond it's not
just a flat color
there's a bit of texture to it and
that's really what you want and once we
once we get our base coat of this of
this camera here we're going to go back
and we're going to add surface
imperfections and that is like
my favorite part because that makes it
feel real it makes it feel
used um it's yeah it's the best it's
just the freaking best
i know those triangles yuck i know
i know all right so that's pretty sweet
let me
let me actually just like select
let me select the entire body of this
thing
and i wanna just get rid of the
top bits i'm gonna have to break this
up
i'm trying to think of the best way
to do this
hmm okay so maybe we grab
well just we just want this top bit here
to be silver so i'm gonna select a
couple polygons
along the top and just hit u y a whole
bunch
and what that does is it grows our
selection
and it usually stops because though this
is
one object like as you can see we can
select this whole thing
usually when people build models online
they combine
together a bunch of different smaller
objects into one object like you're
seeing here
but if we grow that selection it'll stop
at the end
of that particular object in this case
just the top piece
so that's a nice little trick to help
you guys
make selections here um
so what i'm gonna do is go in here and
let's just give that
delete that selection
and ask ourselves let's throw this down
boom so that's
let's reset this
boom there we go so now we applied the
material and it gave us the selection
tag
so let's keep going through and
reference here our actual film camera
and figure out which of these materials
belong
on this now i again for those of you
just joining
um we are texturing a
a modern day dslr to look like an
old-timey
film camera and then we're going to
actually light it and present it as a
product for product photography
and i'm using uh grayscale gorillas
new texture tech texture pack here under
tech materials
it's absolutely incredible it's got a
nice really
amazing wide variety of textures that
i'm using here
um and yeah for those of you guys just
joining
the grayscale gorilla has kindly
provided
you guys with 30 off their
their uh their brand new grayscale
gorilla plus
service where like they got all the
tools all the plugins all the tutorials
packed into plus
um and you guys like 30 off it's a
really solid deal
um christian thanks for the super chat
brother
appreciate you man let's keep going
so we want um more of this silvery
material kind of maybe over
let's see there's like a there's a
brushed silver like this one here i'm
gonna adjust it a little bit
let's go in here and
[Music]
maybe adjust the roughness so let's
get let's maybe boost the gamma of this
roughness
the other direction yeah there we go so
it's more of a
flat um kind of kind of metal there it's
more of a rough metal
all right
so let's see if we can't get an
anisotropic
metal going and if you're like what the
heck did you just say
if you'll notice the the reflections
look at the reflection here you see how
this reflection is more ovally compared
to just this circle
this oval shape um i i don't know the
technical terms or the technical details
i just know it's anisotropic
and it's what you're seeing here on some
of these buttons it'll make sense once i
drop it in a second
see here this material that streak
that's an anisotropic
material there
so let's let's try stereo knob let's
drag out stereo knob
and then let's also drag out
the brushed aluminum coat
let's give these guys a shot and let's
throw it on this button here and see
what we can do now make sure you guys
are saving constantly
saving saving saving so i'm gonna come
in here
and we're gonna we're gonna texture this
thing up really nice i'm
excited so i'm going to go to object
mode select the knob and it looks like
the knob is part of the body so i'm
going to go back to
polygon mode and here's that trick again
i'm going to hit ul that's a loop
selection
and then hit u y i'm going to grow the
selection a whole bunch
and i'm just going to keep hitting it
until i know i got everything selected
on this
and you can see here that i've selected
the entire knob
even though it's a part of the main body
it's because once again the person who
created this camera
basically combined together a bunch of
different objects into one object
and the gross selection little trick
there
is a way for me to quickly select
an entire part even though some of that
some of the parts might be
obscured by other parts of the camera so
let's drop that brushed
look on there and
that's certainly a brushed look but
maybe it's the stereo knob we want
oh wow that's cool um let's take the
stereo knob let's adjust it a little bit
so let's maybe get like some more tiling
in there
wow that looks really nice and you can
slide it around
or maybe change the um
the mapping on it right so we can go
to instead of uv mapping we go cubic
right and then i wonder if there's a way
to get it in the center of this thing
um so instead here let me zero the
offset out
and let's try this let me try another
trick here let's go instead of uv let's
set it to uv let's go
into the material and
[Music]
the stereo specifically the stereo knob
okay
i'm gonna give it a projection i'm gonna
give all these guys projection
nodes i'm gonna set
all these projections to box
okay and then we need to adjust the
transform so i'm going to select all
them
and let's do
roughness metallic base color normal
let's give it a transform
and see if we can't
select all of this
a little confusing here
we just want to select all those
transforms and then get it down to like
point two
so it looks like it's giving us the same
look that same
uh perspective there
but that actually looks quite nice
that nice chromed out look
um let's continue so i'm gonna keep
going through here maybe these buttons
maybe this guy could be
our base material
boom right in there that's looking nice
is certainly going to be like a brushed
the hot shoe there is going to be like a
nice brushed aluminum
or you know we can keep mixing it up and
just have fun and decide
maybe not let's find something else that
could work for that
oh there's the knurled metal stuff that
could work nice for those
for those knobs
oh steel connector
now we'll definitely need some glass for
the lens so i'll drag these guys out
i'm actually going to duplicate the
headphone texture
and let's take the roughness back to its
original
gamma which was 2.2 i believe
and i'm gonna apply that to the hot shoe
or was it one
it was one
awesome um so let's try and
get some like camera grip going i know
they have a texture for that which is
great
so under tech products in the grayscale
gorilla
hub here let's try and find
so there's cam there's two different
camera grips let's test them out
let's test both of them out
so the first one
let's see let's go to our object here
the leather arm
it looks like yep that's going to be the
leather so let's pop that guy in there
that looks really nice just
by default that looks really nice i'm
going to try and scale it up a little
bit
oh that's great that is fantastic
um another thing i'm doing here with the
lighting is
i have a psych up here and a psych is
basically
what you're looking at this background
it's a curved background
um so you know this is actually a way
that you can make it look
like an endless seamless kind of
background setup here
and i'm using just again an hdri um
also from grayscale gorilla to to light
this right now
and we'll dive into the lighting the
specifics of lighting once we get this
thing fully textured
but the background it's actually really
cool you can go to
your grayscale gorilla tab here and you
get this with plus
grayscale girl plus basically go to
psych types and you can get
all different kinds of sites um that
work for you you can get like a corner
one
like this here if we decide that this
corner one is better for us
and you can make it whatever color you
want you know we could do like uh
i don't know
you know anything like this and you can
get some really cool
fun looks this way um get that seamless
background going
maybe we do like an orange
and like this this is really fun in the
end here
once your full thing is textured and
then we start going through the
different lighting types and the
different backgrounds and everything
it just makes it really really easy but
for our sake you know i'm just going to
go back
to what we were doing and we're going to
keep texturing this thing out and keep
dropping different materials on this to
make it look as nice as possible
make sure you guys are saving please
please save save your work do not lose
your work
i've done it before and it sucks
all right so depending on the angle
we're looking at this you know we might
be able to take that hand grip
texture and scale it
up even further
to really get the the look of that going
and
i'm again i'm trying to match i'm trying
to make this
modern day dslr look and feel like this
old-timey film camera
not that this looks too old-timey but it
definitely has a look to it it's that
silver
kind of look versus um you know
the all-black look that you would have
on a
on a dslr today
so for me it's like the middle of the
camera is black
but the tops of the camera is that like
silvery color
so maybe the camera grip here
if i were to deselect this bit
maybe deselect that bit
oh it's underground
let's fix that
there we go now it's actually sitting on
the ground here
very nice
all right let's get let's texture up
just these little bits i'm just going to
be throwing down
boom that's looking good nice and shiny
we'll do the same here
nice and shiny we can always adjust
these
these textures as well
now for the shininess let's go in here i
want to see maybe it's the the base
color
it needs to maybe come up
or down rather to brighten itself up
just a bit
yep i want that to be a bit brighter
cool and i'll apply that to the other
handle as well
wonderful wonderful now for the screws
let's go with that like
brushed metal look
or maybe it's the yeah that's nice
that's really really nice like that a
lot
so i am going to do this really quick
just because
it's a big it's a big step for me and
that's the surface imperfections all
right so with the headphones
let's go in or not the headphones the uh
this this brush metal look
let's go into the roughness all right
and this is what i want to add a surface
imperfection too
so let's get rid of the roughness all
right let's just get rid of it
um and it's basically chromed out at
this point
let me um
go into the roughness channel here and
maybe set the roughness to
0.2 and that's going to break up the
specular highlight and make it appear
more
matte right that's the idea but what i
want to do is grab
like a fingerprint texture so i'm gonna
you know drag out the roughness node
make an image texture
and i'm going to find and navigate to
i got some surface imperfections i've
been working on
and i got some really nice like
fingerprint smudge guys right here that
i
am a big fan of so let me go ahead and
load those in
and the scaling is probably going to be
all off
at first so let me just make a
projection set at the box
and we can solo the node so we can see
what's going on we can see the scale of
it properly
all right and then let's go ahead and
just scale this thing down
great and then we can actually move it
around here too i think for some reason
it's on the psych
i don't want it on the site
all right still i'm going to scale it
down 0.1
and then we can transform it around so
we can find like a good like little
fingerprint
or a good like maybe it's still too
large
0.05 there we go
get some nice fingerprint smudges on
this thing
and maybe it does need to go 0.1 instead
cool um now i'm going to turn that off
it's still to chrome so i think what i
need to do is invert it
or maybe instead of inverting we do
gamma one
because these are all 16 bit and your
smudges are going to
turn it more reflective or less
reflective depending what we want so
it's too much right now it's like
the extremes are too high
so what i'm going to do is grab
[Music]
a gradient octane gradient pop it in
here
and it's going from black to white if i
were to crank it in any direction
it's going to you know just like you do
with levels it's going to add contrast
until
you know we get to something like this
it's too much what i want to do i think
first is
invert it so by default it's the
the metal that is rough and then the
fingerprints are adding
a bit more specular highlight to it
and the the first thing i like to do is
match these colors so i figure okay this
is where i'm at
this is my base level and this doesn't
look good for metal
so i'm going to come down to like a dark
i'm sorry i'm going to come down to like
just a gray and that
is looking better you know that's
actually looking and feeling a bit more
like the metal on my film camera
so from this point what i'm going to do
is i'm going to take one of these and
start going towards black
wrong way so i want to undo that let's
do the other way is black
and that is going to appear actually
more reflective so these are
fingerprints that are looking reflective
right now
so i think we want i think we want the
opposite where we want
the fingerprints to make it appear more
matte
so i'll take that all the way to white
or close to it and i'll bring this down
to black just a little bit
something like this
something like this feels is starting to
feel
right
and i'm going to take the scale down
0.08
and you get a very subtle surface
imperfection across
you know the front of this thing and
it's going to be all over the entire
camera
you're going to have that glossy look
with the fingerprints
across the entire camera and the smudges
and stuff
so that's a very subtle thing that i
like to do
is add surface imperfections they're
super important so let's keep
going um let me try doing like a knurled
metal across this knob right here i want
to see if this will
work so i'm going to do a selection here
and let's go to the grayscale gorilla
plus
library we'll go to tech products and
let's find
knurled metal
here we are one and two i think
two well screw it you know it's so fast
to do this let's just grab both
and i'm gonna pop both of these let's
try with start with one
and dang that is good like
already that's so cool you know you get
a nice broken up knurled metal look and
you can always
come down here and adjust you know do we
want
to have have it be a little larger
i wonder do we set it to cubic
and that just looks nice man that looks
really really nice
i like that a lot
okay good question so one of you guys
asked doesn't octane have its own noises
yes octane does have its own noises and
if you're talking about using those
noises as
surface imperfections you can certainly
do so
but there are certain imperfections like
fingerprints or scratches
or water spots that cannot be made with
noise unless you're in a very specific
program maybe like
a substance designer
you know where you have a lot more noise
options but what i like to do is make my
custom surface imperfections that's
really the way to go it's really fun to
make and i got a tutorial on it coming
out
in the next couple weeks right over
christmas i'm gonna be
releasing a surface imperfection pack as
well
very excited for it but maybe we'll get
into it maybe we'll use it next week on
the stream
um so
let's keep going dude this freaking
knurled metal looks so good
it looks so good here's another one okay
so this one is a bit more like a
vertical situation
i like this one man that's looking good
very nice make sure you guys save your
work
i'm saving iterations so i can always go
back
and check stuff so let's keep
going y'all let's keep going okay let's
do
keep going across the top now these are
little buttons here that i think could
probably be
um like a shiny metal as well
okay so i'm going to go in here
select our guys and for whatever reason
it's like super low poly but that's okay
we got both of those selected um
let's go ahead and grab maybe the stereo
so it's like a shiny kind of a shiny
metal
or the brushed could work
but you know maybe we're going with the
metallic
kind of vibe here more of a rough
kind of vibe um or the finger the one
with the fingerprints you know we just
keep rolling with that
i think that's uh not a bad not a bad
deal
now i do want something that is like
straight chrome i think this brush
totally works for that um
we have to ask ourself do we want
the top of this handle or the top of
this grip
to be
to be metal or to be like this black
plastic
and i'm not sure yet um
i'm not sure i'm very i i hop all over
the place so i hope you guys can follow
what the heck is going on here
because i get very excited with
different stuff like this
i'm looking at this knob and i want to
do it the same knurled look as that one
so i wonder if we can do this very
quickly and very easily
you know or maybe just do stereo
but i think that knurled look is the way
to go it's really nice looking
so what i'm gonna do is i will spawn
well maybe we just grab this guy
and we control drag them out here
scale it down
and we just pop this thing in here
we just kind of replace it
i think that looks way cooler
way nicer
very nice very very nice
so let me hide the lens
here because we'll get into that
now this lens part that looks to me like
the actual lens
so might as well drop some glass on it
which looks great it looks like it
actually has some surface imperfections
built in that grayscale gorilla
goodness i'm loving these tech materials
oh wow that looks amazing
but i'ma hide it i'ma hide it for now
so referencing my film camera
um we are lucky enough to not have any
buttons over here on this side
let's get this grip going let's keep
working on the grip so
the grip here we have two options
in the in the grayscale gorilla tech
materials we got grip number two on here
but let's see what grip number one looks
like
and it's a bit more of a fine kind of
texture it looks like
i kind of like the first one better yeah
i feel like i like this first one better
just working the scale there and let's
see if we can't get this grip
across the front face of this camera
we'll see how this works out
and i'm going to hide this background
i'm going to hide the psych from our
viewport here
i'm also going to hide the grid by going
filter work plane and get rid of that
and the octane sky we can hide that from
viewport as well
i'm not going to worry too much about
texturing the bottom bottom of this
thing because we're probably not going
to see it
but i do want to see about getting in
here and
making a selection across the bottom
of this front face here so let's go into
a side view
let's hide our camera from viewport
and let's see what we can see here i
basically want to get the bottom
piece and make
a cut not a cut a selection across
the bottom here um
so it looks to me like something like
that
and we're gonna deselect all the little
bits that
don't go along the bottom here let's
select
or deselect only select visible so that
we're just cutting through everything
and i just want this bottom bit
that's perfect
this is even good too
yeah what might as well get all of this
good stuff
as well
up to the top
right in here
wonderful okay and then i'm just gonna
deselect this stuff on the bottom
i think the easiest way to do that is to
probably come back into side view hit
zero
for your rectangular mask tool and
just hold ctrl and slice the bottom
so i got most of it but we still want to
get just a little bit more
and i think this we can actually
deselect on our own
holding down control for that
awesome and then i'll apply that brushed
metal to the bottom as well
so you can see that brush metal is down
there too
and up the side of our camera as well
so that looks really nice
awesome so that's a selection we made a
selection by default
getting in there um
by applying that material so we can
always go back to that selection
right we've saved it now i'm going to
see if i can't let's hold shift
hmm is there a way to select both of
these at the same time
i don't know
so i'm gonna do the expand selection
trick
to just get that top piece because i
want i want everything
basically well no this actually should
work if i hit ui
it'll invert that but i don't want the
rest of that stuff i just want the
face of this
[Music]
hmm
so i can get all of this
perfect then we hit ui to invert
selection and let's put that
that that grip right there on the front
okay so that doesn't quite look right to
me
but no worries because we're going to
make it a little smaller i'm going to
come in here
and let's go ahead and set it to 2
and that way the material kind of breaks
itself up just a little bit
or rather it makes itself a little bit
smaller i think maybe 2.2 and 2.2
is good on sizing it matches the hand
grip
nicely
awesome um king mukduk
yo appreciate it man thank you for the
super chat
um have i seen brigade for octane
i have not actually i've not seen
brigade
i know they have a lot of really cool
stuff that they're developing like their
light field
stuff as well it's freaking crazy um but
there's a lot to dive into yo what's up
casey
mr edwards in the house um guys you
might
casey might join us next week we'll see
we'll see no pressure
um but uh doing a little bit of album
art right now
and uh we'll see if we can't get
something cool maybe it'll be next
week's stream who knows
who knows no promises you know me and
casey we got stuff going on
but maybe we'll line it up we'll see
about that
if you guys don't know casey he did he's
an amazing composer and he did the music
for the render montage so everyone say
hey to casey
um freaking crushing it man crushing it
also did some music for uh devil may cry
that's pretty sweet that's among other
things
freaking awesome okay let's keep
texturing guys
because we're here to do so that we can
light things because i'm excited to
light
all right let's do this grip right here
as a metal
let's get in here and let's pop that
right on there so it's looking really
nice
and i might adjust the headphone
roughness just a bit
just so it's a little bit more subdued
very cool because i want there to be
contrast between the chrome material
and um
and the rough metal look all right so
i'm going to try and get this button
looking really nice right now
let's see if we can't just freaking go
to chrome town on it
and make it look great
so this is all one piece i think what
i'm gonna do is
select this bit and then so i hit ul
that's ring selection
right and i'm going to hit u y and to
grow that selection
oh we got lucky because that
is one piece there let's
throw
this chrome look on there but then let's
also get the sides i want the knurled
look on the sides
and then we're gonna need to scale down
that selection here
or rather yeah we're gonna scale it down
so we're gonna up the tiling
there we go looks
really nice
and let's get the rest of this
set to that chrome as well
and this piece here
can be i don't know
i just want to go for visual contrast
maybe we get that black plastic in there
why not
oh wow jeez
nishan thank you very much that is very
generous of you
wow that is one of the uh one of the
biggest super chats i've gotten in a
while
thank you very much no message too just
straight up just like yo
just dropping it here dropping like a
hot dude thank you so much that's great
man you guys are awesome thank you for
supporting the super chat means a lot it
helps me uh
make this a thing um and
also you know our sponsor today is
grayskill gorilla
you guys probably know at this at this
point you guys y'all probably know
but it definitely helps me too if you
guys go to that link down below in the
description
um consider com consider getting grace
go gorilla plus it's what taught
me how to use cinema 4d and it's why i'm
here
teaching you guys today um so
for a year i think it's like 250 260
something
with my 30 off um
and for that price it's really just
a lifetime a freaking wealth of
knowledge and
information that you guys can use to
grow your value so if you're serious
about it if you're serious about cinema
4d
definitely check it out consider using
this the code um it helps me out also
because it's like hey you know the
sponsors
see that i'm doing a killing you know
doing a good job they'll be like yo we
got you on the next one too
um so yeah it's all good all good stuff
y'all are awesome um
you know but you guys can uh
you guys can also just hang out no i
don't need to ask for nothing
i just hope you're having a good time
hope you're learning stuff okay let's
keep going yeah
this little button down here so i have a
similar button on my camera
um let's see if we can't just select
this guy
and get the edge there perfect
let's get that metallic and then we'll
get this one
and we'll make it the like maybe stereo
knob or something
beautiful and we can take this hdri and
rotate it around to get a different
lighting look
maybe something more dramatic you know a
really harsh side light
let's do let's change out the hdri so
i'm going to go into octane sky
and let's see if we can't find something
that looks nice for us
um now we're dealing with metal so
grayscale gorilla actually has
hdris that specifically are here to make
metal look
really nice so let's try 35 let's try
this guy and see what we can get
out of it if i rotate this around
and let's change the power to like three
now this one's okay let's try another
one
well these ones are crazy
super shiny very very nice
god looks so good i love edge lighting
and back lighting my stuff
um and we're gonna again we're gonna get
into the very specific lighting setups
here but i'm just using
hdris to help me get a sense of like
what this is looking like generally
right now
um let me throw in a quick
octane area light i'm gonna rotate it
move
it up and here's actually a really
really cool thing so basically
um grayscale gorilla also offers like
these
area light maps which you can use
to basically change the look of your
light let me show you what i mean so if
i select the light tag in octane
you can do this with any any renderer
no worries go to the texture and we're
going to load a texture image here
and if i go to
where would you be grayscale
area light maps and you can actually
choose real lights real looking lights
and it'll reflect real looking lights to
give you
a realistic look so maybe
we're looking for something like we want
a top light
top-down light a kino bank that's what
we want we want a keynote bank
so it's actually going to emit light
that looks
like you know an actual
you know kino setup like this here so
you'll get that in the reflections and
it'll be really nice
but i just want that top down look um
let's bring this a little bit let's
actually
scale it up
it's obviously way too intense so
what we could do is just bring the you
know bring the lighting down a bit
if we say zero it's just off if we go 10
we get a little bit of that top light
going really really nice
um
[Music]
all right all right let's try turning
off the hdri
or rather let's copy the hdri and
instead of an image we're just going to
make it a color
and it's going to be black so we're in a
dark void and now we're just looking at
you know this top light that's lighting
our
our camera we can get in all close
and really you want to like up the depth
of field so in octane with the
the camera tag here if you go to thin
hello yes
car keys i do
have fun love you all right
um so we want to get the actual some
depth of field on this to make it look
really nice so depth of field make sure
auto focus is unchecked
under thin lens all right set it to like
1.2
it's craziness all right i know but hit
the little f here that's for focus and
we're going to select
where we want to look at and where we
want to focus on our camera 1.2 is way
too much
2.8 is still too much 5.6
and we could just set it to autofocus
here
and it's going to focus on you know
whatever this little plus sign is on
essentially
um mobius yo what's up man thank you for
the super chat
and yes yes you trying to get that
interview
i understand i've been a busy boy i've
been a very busy man um
we'll see we will see if we can make it
happen dude a lot going on a lot on the
schedule
um but i saw your discord message and
i'll be sure to get back to you
all right
richard are you you're asking if i'm
planning on switching to blender anytime
soon
the answer is no i'm not planning on
switching to blender dude i'm deep into
c4d man i love it i love my c4d just
like you love your blender
but keep using blender keep keep going
with it man if it works for you please
do all right
um you know i'm just in c4d land i'm
loving it
i love it so much
all right let's keep
going y'all let's keep going okay so
maybe this top piece to match the film
camera maybe we do a little something
like this where we select all this stuff
maybe we get down to this point right in
here
and we select all the polygons to go
along this line
and this may not work you know this may
actually
not be the nicest looking look but hey
we can try it because that's what we're
we have the ability to do so we're in 3d
you know
so might as well and let's make that the
camera grip
and it's very large so let's take down
let's let's make it you know tile five
times or something
and i'm not a fan of that i'm gonna undo
that very fast
very fast i don't dig it
all good
snap we got nishanth raj with another
super chat
dropping the big bucks dude um
much appreciated dude it's indian rupees
um don't have the option to change the
currency dude that's amazing man holy
crap
thank you for the super chat um i love
it
freaking love it dude absolutely
wonderful very kind very generous of you
thank you so much
i hope you're learning something mr raj
i hope you're learning something
yes hello
uh oh what do i do
okay yo yo here's what here's what's
going on right now
i gotta move my car but y'all stay put
because i'm gonna put up a video for
y'all
and you're gonna just check out the
video
and it's gonna be awesome and i'll be
back in literally
two minutes all right and then we're
gonna keep texturing we're gonna light
and it's gonna look super nice okay
but in the meantime i'm gonna throw on
the render montage i put together
um you know i'm real happy with how the
video's doing
it's it's blowing up i'll see you guys
soon all right two two minutes give me
two minutes i gotta move my car
my fiance is trying to get out of here
spend some time with my friends on the
weekend
shout out to casey edwards um
you all know you want that 1080. all
right i'll see you guys in a second two
seconds right
and we're back we are back we are back
we are back
all right
it's a good video if you guys haven't
seen this check it out casey wrote music
to it and it's incredible
it is absolutely incredible um we're
back in guys we're
you know texturing up a camera making it
look really nice
good times all right
so let's keep going um
yeah yeah let's bring our hdri back in
that's helping us get a little bit of
side light going
absolutely wonderful and we can change
this out for whatever the heck we want
any of these pro studios hdris
which gets you in that studio real quick
really quick
beautiful absolutely beautiful
i mean you could for the ground go all
black
and then be like you know what yo
instead of diffuse let's go glossy
and now all of a sudden you're glossing
out
and then maybe you just up the roughness
a little bit
um you take the roughness and you set it
to like point one
and it gets you just that little bit
that little something
that's nice and then here here's a
little sneak peek for y'all
my surface imperfection pack we got
roughness let's adjust the roughness
let's put up
image in here and let's be like hmm
do we want um
maybe like some people walked over this
thing
so that's why i got my footprints for
you
boom we got footprints up on this ground
let's set the projection the transform
projections always box
okay um let's take the gamma to one
and let's take the transform let's solo
it so we can see what's going on
let's take the transform to 0.5 so we
got some footprints
on this ground you know
really nice nice looking footprints and
let's scale it down even further
0.35
0.2 perhaps that's a good old footprint
right there
okay um and then let's disable the solo
and then now we've got some footprints
on the ground if i wanna
make it a little bit more subtle i can
take a gradient between the image and
the roughness channel
and here's my trick again remember guys
so
to figure out basically it's a black and
white image
and the more black something is the more
rough the more white
uh the more shiny okay but we need to
figure out which part of the image is
which
so i set both of them to the same color
alright so now i know that white
makes it rough if i set it to black
it makes it shiny so now i know
which way to go so now black is all
shiny
so what i want to do is say that okay
the white parts are the rough parts the
shoe prints
all right so let's crank that i don't
want to be super rough i just want to be
a little rough and i don't want it to be
completely shiny i want to give it a
little bit of
something a little bit of blur down on
there
so that's a way to just kind of bring in
that subtle
subtleness i'm going to set the gamma to
0.5
to essentially give me more out of the
image now these images are 16 bit so
you have the ability to get a lot out of
these things
boom that's looking nice
obviously the background we don't like
that going back there
and i mean we could even
maybe get rid of nope that doesn't work
totally doesn't work
disregard
that looks really nice another classic
lighting setup for something like this
that's like very dramatic
is actually two lights on the side so we
can come in here
and we could do uh one light
blast and blasting you from here and we
hold control
and we duplicate it right holding shift
to snap the angle and then you got a
second light from over here
so that gets you a really nice intense
look here
um obviously we need our lens we're not
done texturing but if i were to get rid
of
the hdri and i were to bring these
lights down to like 20
0.
you know so this gets you like a really
nice
kind of high really sharp
edge on your camera so we can bring in
that top one
so now we have a top and we have two
sides but i could take this one on this
side here let's hop out of the camera
let's grab this light right here
and let's move it out just a little bit
so it starts to wrap around the camera
we get a little bit more here on the
body
and then this is like boom canon
freaking
eos 5 mark 5d commercial whatever you
know
um you guys can start to see how this
will work
and you can go into your octane camera
tag go to camera imager
get that notice our post processing you
crank the post process bloom power
to get the nice bloom and then you crank
the cutoff up
so you're getting that nice little sharp
lens flares popping off super nice
you can also set your spectral intensity
to 0.2
to get a little bit of color in that
thing um
and you could also take your glare let's
see your glare power
crank it up that's intense glare amount
you can just
turn it to one or maybe
three who knows you know two does not
look good
but this is this is i don't like this
look you know but
what you could do is maybe come like
this and then
crank the blur so you got some blur on
it and then you just take the power down
so you get a little bit of something and
then you can
mess with the angle on it just a little
bit
maybe it's straight up maybe it's
straight out to the side which can look
kind of cool
maybe more anamorphic style going there
but you can see how like the subtle
surface imperfections
and how easy it is to use the grayscale
gorilla tech
materials it just makes this whole
process like really incredible very fast
and easy to use but let's keep texting
because we're not done yet right
we ain't done seb chen what's going on
welcome
sodamonte you've been in the in the chat
moderating appreciate you man
cheers to you cheers to sonamonte
how's everybody doing guys can i get a
thumbs up
y'all hanging in there y'all having a
good time are you guys learning
that's the most important part is if you
all learning
hope so i certainly hope so
i'm digging this process i really enjoy
making things look nice you know i
really do
let's take this top light let's
duplicate it we'll turn it off
and then we'll maybe bring it down
and make it more of a backlight we'll
scale it down
bring it down here get in close
um control shift z will
undo camera moves
so you can see now that we got a nice
little backlight action so here's the
difference
let's go ahead and
compare we'll store the render buffer so
now we have
a frozen section of our render in a live
section of our render
oh where's like a top well that's weird
okay anyway
let's turn off
let's turn off the top light now it's
looking like this which i'm not a fan of
and then we just turned on the back
light remember we moved that light
around to the back
to get a little bit of that schwing back
there so let me move it
because i ain't done with you let me
move it like
right back in here we'll point it right
here at the
top of this camera we want that swing
it's all about those swing points
you can get those swing points up
you want to cut the light right across
the top of your thing
bam now we will turn off
the light in the viewport okay so what
i'm going to do is select the
octane light tag go to visibility cut it
off all right
it's just a little too much a little too
much sauce on it i'm gonna go back and
forth and you'll see the difference
between the top light
and that god that edge light
and it it's such a big difference that's
the top light it looks all washed out
that's the edge light you really want to
get that contrast that super high
contrast
on your model when you're lighting your
stuff just make it look
make it look really nice you know i'ma
have another cookie
i think i deserve it
the camera's looking really good i'm
finished texturing the crap out of this
thing
i'm gonna get the lens textured up and
then we're gonna keep working on the
lighting
make it look nice get a render going um
[Music]
we could also mess with some different
styles and different lighting styles
like i've said
but let's get it let's get it protected
let's keep working on the texture you
know
too much glow you say huh now we cut it
down
just a little bit just a little a little
something subtle like that
and then we take the thin lens
i want my focus point to be you know the
center of the camera
now you want a little bit of depth of
field just a little bit of depth of
field because it makes you look really
nice
you don't want too much depth of field
though because you won't be able to tell
what the heck the thing is you know
unless you're going like this you know
unless you're like
i'm gonna turn on autofocus
and it's just way too intense 5.6
and you're looking at something like
this you know
and you're getting like close to the
close to the material or something
this is really when you get to see the
surface imperfections
looking really nice and get those subtle
details
because boy oh boy it pays off
man look at that
that's beautiful absolutely
how beautiful
i wonder if i can change the temperature
of these lights
i can wonderful okay wonderful 4300
give a little warmth to it or maybe the
backlight has the warmth
but usually with these camera like these
like camera product shots you don't see
too much
color in it
but i don't know you might see a little
bit of that
just a little bit of something
what's up random guy uh thanks for
thanks for hopping on man um you've been
binge watching previous streams for the
last two weeks heck yeah dude
i'm glad you're learning something
that's great
that's amazing um
yeah this is awesome this is awesome he
says uh
you've you have no idea how much you've
been
a help and there's still so many to
watch i can't wait dude heck yeah man
that's great
that's awesome let's keep going though
let's keep going
for the sake of time i'm just gonna
texture the front of this thing because
you know we ain't got all the time in
the world it's saturday
let's get the lens popping off all right
let's get up in here
what do we see we want to texture this
thing
make it look really nice so for me on my
lens
for my film camera it's a mix between
silver
more chrome a more reflective black
and a matte black okay so we're going to
try and get into these different looks
all right
so let's go the silver let's go silver
boys on
[Music]
on the edge here
all right so we'll grab that silver get
up in there
make it look nice same color as the the
body of the camera
let's keep going in let's see what we
can see
let's go black on this guy black plastic
and then we'll get in even further
and let's do this as
a that chrome
let me get rid of the ridiculous amount
of depth of field here let me help you
guys out just a little bit we can take
that
to 11 maybe it helps a little
all right let's keep going we want
this guy we'll take it as a chrome
and this will be our first this piece
here
maybe this is our first bit of black
plastic yo melanie oh my god
i hadn't heard from you in so long long
time no see absolutely thank you for the
super chat
um hope you're doing great these days
that are liking the new house
thank you thank you we're very happy
happy holidays in case one catch before
christmas say hi to gilbert and teddy
gilbert and teddy they're running around
they're loving the new place man
i don't know where they are
they're probably taking a little nap but
uh they say hello
thank you melanie i appreciate it um
means a whole lot
good to see you very good to see you
it's been a minute
all right let's go back let's go to
grace go gorilla plus library let's go
to the tech products and let's see if we
can't find a nice uh
okay here's a glossy plastic that we're
going to
adjust we're going to adjust this a
little bit let's bust it out let's drop
it on
and it's going to hopefully do a thing
absolutely
so we have a glossy black plastic right
in here
now i personally think it's a little
too glossy oh but they have a roughness
they have a nice little roughness wow
wait those are those are my own
roughness
that's my own roughness um surface
imperfections
that's great here let me try dropping
that on here i actually like that a lot
that's really nice let's keep going
let's grab all these guys and let's try
and go for more of
yeah that matte plastic so i'll drop
that mat on there
and then we'll get that same shiny
on this guy here as well as this guy
here
boom
so that's too shiny i don't know what
happened there
all right so maybe the camera grip
can be a bit darker
so the base color can come up to like
three in terms of gamma
just to give it a little bit more sauce
this black
plastic is a bit
too dark
so i'll boost it up just a little bit
now we have a lens going on in here
whoa
oh that's nice they even got some like
aperture situation going let's throw
some plastic on the aperture
oh and that's the whole lens but that
kind of looks nice to be honest
so maybe maybe we do that maybe we do
the whole lens
as like
so here's the trick i want to move this
lens out of the way actually no i just
i'll hide it i'll double click it i'll
double click these little lights
drop this plastic on and then we'll
bring it back in so we have the glass
going
and then i'll come in here and i'll do a
little spot detail on
um you know these different pieces so i
know that like
like we said
this guy we want to be that
chrome material so we'll drop that on
and you'll get that there that's looking
good it's looking really really nice
and we'll come into here and maybe we'll
do
like uh
we'll break this up a bit so like this
piece
and maybe this piece and maybe this
piece can be more of a
reflective plastic
something like that
and then now what i want to do is
actually maybe let's get that one and
let's make that more like a shiny
metal
that's not bad let's save a new
iteration
um asahi [ __ ] what
digital tablet do i use i'm using the
wacom
intuos pro 4 tablet
um it is great i love it
i don't have any room to show this is
about it this is about all i can show
because it's all attached
but yeah i'm loving it it's the best
it's the absolute best it's great
it saves my wrist from getting hurt
you know using a mouse too long no good
all right so here's what i want to do
to take this to the next level so
let's start with this
this chrome material okay i want to give
it scratches
on the edges of this thing and i think
that's really going to make this thing
shine it's going to make it look really
cool all right so the first thing i need
to do is come up with a material
that's going to be the base coat the
underneath part so
i'm going to go back to the plus library
go back to tech products and let's see
if we can't find a gold
this is perfect a gold connector
headphone connector this like brass
works as well so let's grab the brass
bring it in here okay and let's just pop
it on the camera
and see
what we can see i just want to get the
scaling right i want to throw it on
something
to get the scale right so let's just
throw it down here or something
and it looks like there's not much going
on in terms of texture which is fine
it's a metal um and that actually looks
good to me so i'm going to go ahead and
move on
what i'm going to do here i'm going to
use a mixed material
um so i'm going to spawn one here you
can also go to objects
sorry materials and you can go to octane
mix material you can also type it in so
hit
shift c and you can look up anything
here
in cinema 4d it makes materialist right
there i'm going to open it up let's hop
inside of the mix material and the mix
material is
asking for two materials so i'm going to
give it the headphones
this like you know rough
reflective silver we have for the for
the
camera body and then i'm going to give
it that gold um
kind of connector piece there
let's put that in the material two okay
so now what we want to do
is we want to mix between these two
materials in a very specific way
okay so
let's see here i want to get rid of this
float texture
all right so that goes bye-bye um
so let's hop in here and let's see what
we can see all right
so this mixed material we actually need
to drop
on where do we want to start
let's start with this base right here
the camera body i'm just going to
replace
i'm going to drop this mix material over
top
every spot where we have that original
material i want to
i need to replace it so the easiest way
is to just get in here and just drop
them
over like this so now you can see that
they're like
silver or like rose gold almost looking
on this thing which is not what we want
we need to break it up and mix it up and
we're going to do that with a dirt node
so i'm going to type in dirt bring that
up
and let's invert it
and we actually it looks like we need to
switch our materials so
material basically we need to switch the
slots
because now
if i take the strength up to 10
let me see if i can get to a spot where
i can like see this better
i'll render the region
so there you go you can see here that
on the edges we're getting that gold
material
and on the front face we're getting
um the silver okay
so with the dirt map you can take the
radius you know and go to different
different bits on the radius you can say
oh i want to cover a larger area
so that's too much 0.2 maybe instead or
maybe it's 0.3
um you know it's just getting ever
getting all the edges
otherwise it's going to get the crevices
but right now we want the edges like
this
um technically with a product you're not
going to really have something that's
scratched up but i want to give it that
subtleness you know that subtle
subtle imperfection but i like the
radius of 0.1 i thought that was nice
now one thing we don't want to do is to
have a uniform scratch across the entire
thing
that doesn't make sense so what we want
to do is break up
the edge of this thing and tell it like
you know i just want
scratches on certain parts of the edge
not across every single edge right
so what we're going to do is break that
up with
either an image texture a black and
white image texture or
a noise map so let's try let's try a
noise map
octane noise we got it now what i like
to do is instead of the dirt node
plug in your noise map plug that into
the amount
and this is going to give you wait
that's the
oh god
okay whoo that was close let's try that
again
octane noise why is it doing an rgb
spectrum what is going on
how about this i'll just type it in
octane noise wonderful the projection
we can set it to xyz to uvw
and then i set the contrast to 100 that
way i'm able to see what's going on
um it's too large so i need to give it a
transform node
and we scale it down let's try point one
there you go now we can see that the
noise map is breaking up those two
textures in a very specific way
um that's actually not bad that's not
bad at all let's take the octaves let's
go to like i don't know
10 which will give it more detail
and the omega we can set to one see that
gives it a lot more detail it gets in
there right
really nice so what i want to do let's
plug the dirt map back in
i want to use this noise map to break up
the dirt map
so to do that i will simply
set let's see i think it's an add
an add node so we'll go dirt and noise
into both pop that in there
and show enough it's a working
let's take a look let's take a closer
look
i think the lights are a little intense
right now
and it makes it difficult to see all
this so
i'm just moving my hdri
around and then we'll just stick with
the hdri for now
and let's see what we can see
and it actually it looks like it's
getting the edges and the crevices
and i think that's just because these
two that's technically an edge
right in here which wouldn't be right
let's give this guy the material as well
and maybe what we need to do is actually
invert the dirt map
nope that's certainly the edges
so maybe what it is the tolerance these
two
or this is the distribution
so someone's it's almost looking like
rust right now
which i'm not a fan of let's try
bringing
the strength down
and then crunching it
like this i think
maybe the transform is just too small
so now i'm just messing with these
settings to get the best
look on this thing
and maybe instead of gold actually
maybe we do
a silver maybe we try silver maybe that
will help
um i'm gonna set it to float which makes
it
um a black and white image and i think
that actually helped
that helped a lot i think it it was
looking like
rust actually with the gold
that feels nicer
and let's give the the psych the
backdrop i'm gonna actually go
with like a dark gray i'm gonna see if
grayscale
gorilla tech products if they have any
like
soft gray or something
like this rubber soft actually might be
nice for this and then we just change
i mean that's actually perfect that is
perfect
all right so now what i'm gonna do
is wrap up the texture here um
let's give this the same rubber look
and then i'm gonna go ahead and give
this little guy
a texture i don't know what this is
black plastic okay
sure why not
and the memory card bit will give that
maybe
uh that camera grip
as well and we'll scale it
up to match
the others all right let's see
wonderful
not bad at all i mean i think the lens
could maybe use a bit more detail
or some imperfections so let's go in
here let's just add a bit of
imperfection to
this material and i'll do that with the
roughness okay
so let me grab another product actually
that grayscale has
in the plus library if you go to
textures
chad ashley has been hard at work making
some awesome scratch
imperfections and what's cool is it's
all here in this
library and you actually be able to just
drag this
out and drop it right in
to your your node tree
boom so you're good to go you don't have
to dig through your computer it's in one
place
so now you can see there's a bit of you
know scratch here on the lens
or at least the plastic part of the lens
not the actual
lens and that gives it just a little bit
of something you know just a little
subtle something let me try
this plastic as well let me go in here
let's give this some scratches too so in
the roughness
i'm going to go ahead and multiply it
with an image texture
of one of the grayscale gorilla
imperfections let's try for more of
a let's try this one this one's cool
drop it on there
what happens if i just plug it right in
that's very subtle
very very subtle oh that's the camera
grip i'm on the wrong material ah
so i want this plastic on the lens right
here
i think that's it yeah plastic here we
go here we go
so let's try it again we're gonna going
to drop multiply in there
and then we'll grab the grayscale
gorilla
surface imperfection scratches
this one was nice drop it in
also now we need to make some
adjustments let me invert this
we'll go to projection we'll give it box
projection
and transform we might need to just
scale it down so i'm going to right
click and solo it to see what we're
doing
let's transform it down to 0.1 maybe
0.05 so we have some very
subtle scratches here
and i'll zoom out to see what that's
doing for us
and it's very very subtle
but it is certainly doing some stuff for
us here i see a little scratch here
and we can probably take that scratch
image and adjust the gamma as well to
give us
more detail maybe we go to three because
it's inverted
there it is
just some subtle scratches on that thing
awesome
sweet alright so this is looking really
cool let's let's get into lighting let's
talk about lighting so i think this is
definitely a vibe here
this like soft light kind of situation
what you'll see a lot in studio
lighting setups let me actually let me
grab
like some wood from bridge real quick
because what you'll see a lot in like a
studio setup is someone will have like a
nice
big open bay windows and they'll let
light
shine through and hit their product from
the side or something
um this is a total like super classic
move
that a lot of product photographers use
i'm gonna grab some wood real quick
from mega scans
interior
hmm
how will we just search for wood
under 3d assets
and see if we can't find like a a
tabletop or something to
to lay this thing down on
so i only got two points i only got two
quick points so maybe i should just be
searching under purchased
this is nice the solid wood flooring
here
awesome um actually let me change
this to octane and try that one more
time
there we go so once you change your
renderer in c4d
uh bridge will recognize it
so let's see let's get rid of the psych
for a second we'll come back to this
look
um let's go ahead and
[Music]
drop a plane down scale it up get our
wood in there
and we'll set this to octane and glossy
maybe take down the saturation
maybe not the biggest fan of this wood
maybe we just do it on a table yeah
ye
all right so let me throw down
this rubber and
you know you can do this with an hdri
certainly so like if i you know come
into the hdris and i grab
any one of these like studio setups
they're basically set up to
light your model as if you would in a
studio and these kind of give the
impression and the feeling
of large soft light which is what you
get with a window it's a large
soft light so these can be wrapped
around your model
you can also hide the
the hdri from the background certainly
so if you wanted to do maybe like uh
how about this how about this like i
said i jump over
all over the place all good
um here's what we can try let's take
this plane
let's control drag it up
90 degrees push it back scale it up
all right
this is a look that you'll see a whole
lot of let's go ahead and grab
one of our let's just make a new octane
light
let's drop it down rotate it up
push it way down
and let's see if we can't get a nice
soft glow off the back of this wall here
so this is a look you'll see a lot of
with
you know um if we had a straight on
camera so i do the camera like uh
and get these numbers i zero these
numbers out boom boom
and then i take the camera itself and
just kind of rotate it around like this
and let's change
let's maybe move our plane
up just a little bit
yeah that's not bad we need to take the
background light
down
something like that and then let's
adjust our
hdri in the foreground
and maybe we change out the hdri image
we can find something a bit more
[Music]
hmm
maybe something like this
there we go there's that nice side light
coming in you can crank that
up just a bit and maybe we want to
get maybe we want to darken the floor
so we could come into our material we
can duplicate it
and we can take the gamma
up
or honestly something we could do
instead
is just give it a color correction node
and take the brightness down to like 0.5
or something and we'll drop that on our
ground or foreground plane
and it should darken up
if i take the brightness to zero i don't
know why that's not
doing a thing is it maybe because of the
roughness
and the reflection so we'll take the
specular down to zero
huh and it's still not doing anything
for me in that case i'm going to just
make my own
drop it on the ground
and we'll bring the diffuse down
and maybe we'll make it a little glossy
like this here
and then we'll get the specular or i'm
sorry the roughness will go like point
one
and maybe it needs a little color so
0.01.01
just so it's not completely dark and
then we can go into our camera
[Music]
and
maybe give it some vignette
to really lock that in
so that's not bad that's certainly
certainly not bad right
but i wonder if we can do better so
let's
let's google let's just google our
reference right so we're looking
for um a sony camera
i'm gonna just google sony camera and
see what comes up
if we go to images now here's the thing
that you're seeing is a lot oh this is
interesting like this look right here
so let me try this let me try going for
something like this
now you could have it floating in space
this might be photoshopped to appear
that way
um this one definitely is you know
with the background on it but i think we
can get something
similar you know especially this look
you always see this on white
this look on white all the time so
how do we do that i think the first
thing you do here
let me save this iteration
the first thing you do i mean usually
you just kind of bust out a psych
so i can go maybe with uh one of these
quarter dome
sikes here um let me
try and make this easier in the viewport
for you guys so we can see what's going
on there we go
i'm gonna hop out of the camera
all right so we're in this like psych
situation
here which is basically just a seamless
background let's get rid of the plane
let's hop in let's get rid of
the vignette
awesome and then we want to boost
the global lighting all right
so one thing you could do
here the way they do this a lot is to
blast
light let's hide all these lights here
and we'll hide this back light in fact
i'm gonna delete it because we can
always open up the other project file
we're saving iterations right
so if we blast light
all around this camera
you'll be able to get a really nice
global effect we're going big lights
here
we want big lights and i'm going to
duplicate it
and we're going to surround this thing
in light from the sides and the top
we'll get this down so we're going to
bounce light off
of the side of the wall so the light
bounces back in
and we'll adjust the intensity in a
second let's just get the placement
right and then we'll do
holding control holding shift to snap
the angle
get that right in there so the lights
let's set the visibility
check uncheck camera visibility let's
get
in here and it's way too intense let's
turn down
let's in fact turn off any post
processing
and let's go ahead and bring down the
exposure
certainly it's way too bright now it's
time to bring down
the lights so let's take the light
intensity to
20 10
maybe it's 15 which is what gives us
a white background
for our camera
which is certainly you know part of that
like
that product photography vibe you know
um
now it's this under light here that i'm
not a fan of another thing i want to do
too is maybe give it a bit more
lighting from the top you can see you're
getting
notice here you can you can see this uh
highlight and then it goes to dark and
it goes to highlight again
those are different lights hitting it at
different angles here
and they're broken up and there's space
between everything in our case it's very
very kind of like flat because we have a
just a massive box around it
so there's no real shape to it so i
think
probably the easiest way to give it some
shape and the easiest way to get
this look right here is to basically do
this
i'm gonna hide the psych
let's try that again i'm gonna hide the
psych
i'm gonna hide our lights
i'm gonna hide our
um let's actually let's let's not hide
the
hdri yet i'm going to duplicate it
and i'm going to make it in a texture or
i'm sorry i'm going to make it a color
so the color i'm going to choose is
white i'm going to set
the type to visible environment so that
means we have a
white sky or a white
color as our background but it's not
coming through so let me just go to my
octane settings
let me adjust all this set your gi clamp
to one
alpha channel keep environment
let's see
why am i not seeing this
maybe let's get rid of that
so it's as a gray background what is the
oh it's because i have a plane
that's why i have a plane in the way so
let's get rid of that plane
i didn't need to do the alpha
so here okay is our white background
with our camera if i make a new
environment and we set it to
basically this blue one which is which
takes images the gray one
takes colors so we'll grab
one of these metal
let's grab this one this crazy one it's
got a lot of cool stuff
a lot of cool variety i'm gonna load
that in
so the idea is that we want
this hdri to light our scene
but we just want this white one as the
background
only
so it should work out hold on this
should work i don't know why it's not
working
maybe it's got a lot of stuff going on
let me find let me make it really
obvious um
oh that's why it's backwards so that's
the primary environment
and then we duplicate it and we make the
color version the white version
the visible environment
that way
you know you have the background which
is always white and
the model itself which is being lit by
another hdr
but this looks like butt so i need to
find the right hdr
so i'm just gonna you know cycle through
here
let's try this one
let's rotate it
and let's maybe give it more power i
want to boost it like crazy
so 20 is too much
it's a little dark it's dark in the
foreground so let's do a manual all
right
we're going manual now this is lit
with just it looks like
we want that to be the visible
environment um
let's make a new one and we'll make our
primary environment just black
so now it should just be a black blob
exactly over white okay so this is when
we really start to shape it
this is it looks like a top light is
some of our old lights here
these are some bounce lights that aren't
working but that's okay
i'm gonna save a new iteration
all right so i'm looking at this
and it looks like there's a big old soft
box coming from this side
so what we can do i'm gonna
uncheck check camera option
let's see about getting a big old soft
box so this
light right here if we go to texture and
we
load an image we can actually load
a softbox area light map it's also
greyscale gorilla
also will be included in grayscale
gorilla plus
which you all have 30 off to
in the description below go check it out
um it's an amazing service i've been
using grayscale gorilla
for years now i've been using it for the
entire stream um
it's something that is part of my
professional workflow every single day
in cinema 4d so if you guys are trying
to trying to get in
on that c4d knowledge training um
you know plug-ins uh materials tools
all that good stuff check them out
grayscale gorilla
get that plus link anyway back to it so
these are lights from grayscale gorilla
we
want a large soft
kind of situation let's go with this
umbrella diffuse
so the umbrella diffuse is a big soft
light
that let's go ahead and rotate our
camera back
here and i'm gonna hop into
the camera
let's go with 85 and try and match this
look
all right so let's get this big soft box
over to the side here it looks like it's
kind of doing one of these maneuvers
something like this
based off of this image and then you
have another fill light right here i'm
looking at the reflections you have
another
fill light right in here
so that to me could be a smaller
soft box or maybe some kinos but
probably not it's probably another
small soft box
so i will duplicate
this material or this light here let's
wing it around
180
and we will
bring it around to the front just a
little bit i'm going to scale it down a
bit
and i'm going to change out the texture
of this thing so
let's give it um it's like it's gonna
definitely be another soft box
softbox circle
softbox large yeah let's go for that
and we'll bring it in close
now we have it looks like the underside
um it needs like a front light
something to fill all the areas that are
a little dark
specifically from the front so i'm going
to
duplicate this again and let's zero out
its rotational settings
so it's right in front and maybe
a little maybe it's a little above
angle it down just the hair pick it up
and this one let's make it a ring light
so yeah let's try an led ring light
and you're seeing the reflection the
reflection of that ring light
right in the lens which i kind of don't
want
but let's see what we can see in this
lens it looks like it's photoshopped the
lens is definitely photoshopped
they took out all the reflections of the
cameraman and that kind of good stuff
it also looks like it's getting hit by a
backlight up here so let's go ahead and
do
do a backlight situation now we
we probably don't need much of a
backlight just because this is silver
and maybe against black is a better look
because you have that silver and you
want that silver to pop
um you know in this case the silver is
against
black so it looks good
this is kind of doing it actually this
is this is awesome this is kind of
exactly what we're going for
i really like that uh that style
now you could hit it with a bounce card
simply by making a plane
rotating this plane pushing it back
lowering it just a bit
scaling it down
and give it a material
and that material depending on you know
depending on what color that material is
you can either make it a bounce card
like it is now where it's white or if
you zero it out so it's all black
it's a flag meaning it's blocking light
so maybe we just do something subtle
like that
and maybe let's try changing out our
background color
for fun
maybe it's black maybe it's you know
a fun kind of teal color like we saw in
one of those earlier ones
and here's the situation you see this
this knob is reflective
and it's not reflecting any light
because there's no light behind it so
if we hop out of the camera here i want
to see this
light in the reflection of this knob
so i have to move it over
or honestly make another one scale it
down
rotate it
move it down until it's right in there
yeah so i hope you all are learning
something learning how to
light and get your product photography
looking really nice
i know i really enjoy this process
yeah very fun very very fun
so i mean do you guys want to cover any
other
sort of stuff here before we wrap this
out and do the weekly challenge
do you want to do any other like
lighting setups here
um i'll leave it to you guys
i think we covered quite a bit here
yeah this is this is like really fun i
could just mess with this all day long
you
um john malcolm so
the grayscale gorilla guys basically
have what you're asking for
um it doesn't feature the studio hdris
they don't feature any lit
lamps um
they
are specifically kind of like blobby
white and black toned images
like this you know there's no studio
lamps
really involved
so it can be really nice
it's got a whole wide variety um
let's get this camera off the ground
all right
wow that's orange that is super orange
jeez
all right y'all that was fun i had a
good time doing that
it's always good it's always a good time
like
lighting stuff making it look nice
man i could just go to town on this
though you know it's like i could keep
doing this over
and and like just getting really nice
looks out of everything
get that edge light going
good times very good times all right i'm
gonna save my last iteration
boom okay
so y'all two things to do before we wrap
up the stream
one announce the winners for the weekly
uh challenge that i hold every single
week this week was neon that was the
challenge
all right and two announced the winners
for the expanding dimensions
challenge or not rather not challenge
but giveaway that i'm doing with pny and
nvidia
so let me let me start with the
expanding dimensions
winners let me pull up the page here
and we will let's go ahead and announce
these guys uh joshua
thank you for the super chat brother
much appreciated you love the stream
you think i do some killer art i think
that's awesome man thank you so much
really appreciate it thanks for sticking
in and hanging out
it's been fun um so all right so
for the let me double check here that we
[Music]
want to make sure i got the the right
winners here all right here we go
for the expanding dimensions contest
we are giving away some good stuff we
got
first place first giveaway for
the nvidia quadro rtx 4000
we are giving that away to none other
than jeremy delaney
mr jeremy delany congratulations you
have won the nvidia quadro rtx 4000
i hope it amps up your computing
experience
um it's been an amazing time doing this
with uh with nvidia and pny this year
we did the parallel dimensions contest
the render um
you know contest with all the montages
going
uh we did that earlier this year um
like really just like a month ago and
this was the expanding dimensions
contest where it's just a raffle
random giveaways here y'all random
giveaways and we're giving away
the quadro rtx 4000 to mr jeremy delaney
congratulations jeremy
next up the nvidia shield tv
pro who's it going to well
it's going to mr zombiet
a acharya apologies if i mess that up
and it might be misses uh sambit
acharya you've won the nvidia shield tv
pro congratulations
congratulations i hope it uh
i hope it makes your tv experience that
much better
so next up
[Music]
next up we have some
ssds to give away if you guys know what
ssds are basically they're solid state
drives they don't have any moving parts
so they
you're able to pull up your files much
faster you're able to work
much faster and we got two of those to
give away today all right
the first one the first one terabyte ssd
is going to nicholas houseman
congratulations nicholas you are winning
a one terabyte sse
dude i don't even have a one terabyte
ssd that's a great prize
so i hope you use it and i hope it makes
your computing experience a whole lot
faster
and we got one more as well to joe louis
corporal we got you with a one terabyte
ssd
congratulations congratulations
amazing amazing amazing
and last but not least technically we
got two
two of these flash drives to give away
um the first one is going to eric
williams
congratulations don't lose it it's tiny
all right
technology's getting a lot smaller these
days so don't lose it
keep it on your i don't know
keep it around a necklace or something
that thing is tiny
but it's a usb 3.1 256 gigabyte gigabyte
flash drive
congratulations eric williams you got it
it's coming your way
um and the last one's pending because we
need to make sure that that person is in
the u.s
we'll reach out you guys will uh we'll
be in touch all right
all y'all congratulations for winning
the prizes um
i hope it makes your computing
experience better you know keep watching
the stream i'll let you guys know
follow me on instagram it's underscore
punisher underscore
um freaking subscribe to me here on
youtube if you guys want to catch some
more of these challenges
some more of these prizes because it's a
good time it's a very good time
all right y'all heck yeah
heck yeah
okay here we go so now
we got this out the way right we
finished our lesson
we finished our cinema 4d lesson
so now what we're doing is
the neon challenge all right
so here's what we're gonna do let's go
ahead and uh open up the discord
and pull these vids
and picks because we got a lot of good
submissions this week
i'll make sure yeah we look to be good
here
and i'm gonna do this um
let's see there's a whole lot yeah
there's a whole lot there's a whole lot
of good ones
and it gets tougher and tougher to do
these because you guys are really
killing it you're really doing a really
great job
um so
we got five winners for the neon
the neon challenge
so let's break it down first up
we have
hazelnut spread with this ramen video
let me see if i can get this
uh downloaded
and we're gonna pop it off boom hazelnut
spread
come on come on come on open my friend
what's going on here why no work
hold on y'all bear with me
here we go hold on hold on i think i
need to i need to share the other screen
because it's on the other screen
let's see if this works oh it's gonna be
crazy
because i have obs on one
uh come on there we go
there it is look at this cool loop
i dig it i really dig it i love the
colors
i love the surface imperfections you got
going the chopsticks back and forth you
actually modeled out like the neon sign
um properly it looks really nice
i'm a fan of it i'm a big fan
um yeah hazelnut spread congratulations
the first winner
of this week's challenge here neon
challenge all right let me get the
screens going let me get the screens
back
that was the video all right hold on uh
not the right model with the left
monitor absolutely apologies technical
difficulties guys i'm gonna get better
i'm gonna get better at this all right
i'm gonna get better at the streams
um next up we have
ya boy who's always crushing it
all the time and that has missed their
visual
so good look at those colors man look at
those colors
wonderful absolutely wonderful i love
the composition i love the character
um and the colors really it comes down
to the colors and you got the rain
coming down on the back wall there
a little large maybe on the the rain
imperfections but i'm loving it
i'm loving it i think it's really really
really nice so congratulations
visual you're a challenge winner this
week
it happens often visual you know you're
crushing you crush a lot
and hazelnut spread you're also a
challenger this week all right but let's
keep going
we got three more
to go over okay
all right let's see if i can say this
right
let me save the image
get it going over here mr
ankle am i saying this right
it's this image here um
let's see cheap sheep i think
is your name or uncle lucy this is
amazing
this is absolutely incredible i love the
detail that's gone on to this
the way that the cable's dropping down
the stairs coming around back
the detail in here is amazing absolutely
amazing the only thing i'd like to see
is maybe a little bit of
a little bit more glow on this like we
were doing today with the camera
get some glow you got the cut off going
to make this feel really bright but
you have very nice volumetric fog coming
in here or
volumetric lighting the quality on your
stairs are incredible
i don't know if it's like a bridge asset
or what but
man this is really good really really
good
i'm a fan of this for sure
congratulations
i think your name is uh
ankle usey i believe that is correct
um all right who's up next
who is up next who's next who's gonna
take it
i think it's gonna have to be
dead i duck with your render here let me
save it
let me show y'all you know there wasn't
a lot of time to prep for the stream
here
so i'm having to save this stuff out
after the fact as i do it but you guys
have seen it live
bam look at that super cool
love this thing man like you got some
cool tech going over here like a mars
rover status
um you know there's only two things i'd
like to see
that that i think can make this better
is maybe something inside of this ring
and just a bit more detail on the
character
that's it but otherwise i love your
composition i love your colors i think
this looks really cool i love the glow
that you have here
i think that's great um the detail in
the ground is very nice
i like the the low-lying fog i think is
a really really good job
um i'm down i dig it i like the little
like stair
system you built with the statues i
think it's sick so congratulations
deadeye duck you are a challenge winner
this
week and we got one more one more
winner and this person
is very young very very young
but oh so extremely talented
um i think i think he's 13
maybe he's 14 at this point but it's
willy
look at how sick that looks man
incredible absolutely incredible
very filmic very blade runner
i dig it so much
i love this vibe the colors are
fantastic i love the center frame
subject the depth of field you know
you're focused on the character
you even have noise going on color noise
here to make it feel like it's not a
render which i love
always always do that when you get the
chance it's worth it i promise
but these are amazing
these are absolutely amazing
congratulations to all the winners y'all
i'll be adding the uh
the challenge winner discord roll
for y'all on the server if you guys
don't know i do have a server
and i host the weekly challenge every
single week and we're going to come up
with a theme right now so start typing
your suggestions for the challenge for
next week
um but the link to the discord server is
in the description below
uh it's a lot of fun i think people have
a good time with the challenge i love
you know going over and looking at
everyone's work it's so cool to see all
you guys working so hard
and putting in the extra time i love it
so what do we want to do this week guys
let's figure it out what are you guys
trying to do for the weekly challenge
i'm open to everything we got rain
dream is a good one light oh lightning
underwater i think we did an underwater
one already
abandoned city
snow theme we think we've done snow
i mean we have to do a christmas one
soon man
maybe we do oh shoot do we do a
christmas
right now it's coming up i mean
next week is
let me check man next week might be my
last stream
um let me double check this real quick
all right so i gotta stream next week
yeah next week is my last stream y'all
next week is my last stream of the year
and then i'm putting out a surface
imperfection video
either on the 19th or
the 26th
maybe the 19th probably the 19th i'll be
putting out my surface imperfection
video then
but that's when i fly back home so i'll
be taking
the 19th off the surface imperfection
video will come out then
the 26th i will not be streaming
and the second
the first stream of the year saturday
the second
i may or may not stream i mean i'll be
back here by then
but we'll see you know i'll just i need
to take a break i need to take a break
solid break we'll see we'll see where
we're at but next
week is my last stream of the year
so i think guys
it's time dude
it's time to do a freaking christmas
theme
it's freaking christmas like we got to
do a christmas theme
if that means snow globe to you then go
for it you know
if that means toys or candy or
candy canes or whatever go for it the
theme is christmas i think it's pretty
self-explanatory
um whatever christmas means to you all
right
christmas knickknacks christmas dinner
christmas presents christmas tree
freaking christmas candy canes
santa claus i don't care as long as it's
christmas themed
then you know go for it um
yeah throw some eggnog in there i don't
care
but that's it that's the theme for this
next week my last
live stream is christmas all right so
y'all if you're trying to learn c4d
and if you're trying to get real nice
with it
and if you're trying to get access to
the best
plugins the best training and the best
assets
definitely go click the link in the
description below
grayscale gorilla they got a a plus
service which means you get all of their
stuff
for i think if you do it
without the discount it's like 50 bucks
a month
if you do it if you do an annual
subscription
it is
like i don't know it comes out to
400 bucks for the year
but you're saving four months worth if
you get the annual subscription versus
50 bucks a month but if you use my code
clint 30 you're going to save 30 on the
annual subscription
that's 280 guys you're saving a ton
of money 280 bucks for the year to learn
c4d it's how i learned
um so get on it guys
they got all the best plugins training
and assets coming at you over at
grayscale gorilla
their plus membership is totally worth
it give it a shot
use the discount code you all have been
the best thank you so much
um i'll see you next week we got that
christmas coming
up uh mikko thank you for the super chat
we got all the hype going in the room
thank you thank you um
y'all are awesome catch me on instagram
you know
i'll be posting stuff i'll be doing
stories and stuff i'm selling prints
y'all i got limited edition prints going
right now
noisegreeninlight.com it's in the
description as well
check it out the prints the limited
edition prints
once they're gone i will never print
them again
so go over and check it out they're
freaking awesome man look at these
things
i'll show you
bam lemon limited edition
boom these things are nice i've already
sent out a few
we got large size like the let's just
it's a good time y'all pick yourself up
a limited edition print
um or you know just hit the store
and maybe grab some of my photography um
we got 25 percent off all prints right
now except for the limited edition one
um but yeah have a great
freaking week guys enjoy subscribe if
you're not
i'm lingering at this point dude chad
ashley chad ashley
in the stream dude heck yeah
that was awesome man i loved your
scratches it was so easy to use
super easy
ah all right y'all if you got any
questions
i'll be here for the next minute all
right
and after that i'm gonna go drink some
tea
you know because you talk for
nearly three hours straight and your
throat starts to hurt a little bit you
know
you know how it is you guys are awesome
thank you so much for hanging out it's
been a good time
it's been a really awesome time um shout
outs to grayscale gorilla
for putting out the best stuff man i
will i'll go to the grave
shout out now the praise is for
grayscale because that's how i learned
how to do
c4d and get good at it you know so
i hope y'all uh i hope y'all enjoyed
this one i hope you learned something
what are my christmas plans man i'm
going back to atlanta
georgia and i'm going to just relax i'm
going to bring my camera and do some
photography
hang out with friends and see some
family
i'm very excited i need it i need a
break i need a break man it's going to
be a good one
yeah the andrew kramer uh the andrew
kramer episode of vfx artist reacts will
be amazing
it'll hopefully come out before the
years end
next year you should do a backflip
render challenge bring back the park
a backflip render challenge i got you
okay
josh yeah that's where scat is i believe
in
i forget the name of the city but it's
it's over there yeah it's definitely
over there
and william no plans for blender right
now man i'm
i'm a c4d boy right now man i'm really
enjoying it
but uh if you're if you're in blender
keep it up
definitely check out blender guru check
out ian hubert they're the best
ronin progress on your japanese
uh
um
i would say uh i would say taijubu taiji
budas
is going well it is good yes
uh it's very good
i love it i've been practicing japanese
this year once a week
um hoping to go to japan again i've been
there twice
i want to go three times when i go four
times five times
it's the best i love that country so
much
but all right y'all i'm lingering now
i'ma bounce
oh ronan says
con pi i think that's
that doesn't say kanpai it says
kanpaki or something
khan peki what is khan peggy
ah saw this
ah okay kanpeki is perfect
that's a good one i need that one i've
just been saying paw patrol
you know you just throw those out there
but yeah i like kanpaki that's good
japanese garden theme absolutely
all right y'all have a great day i'm out
i'm gonna get some food peace out y'all
have a good one hit me up seeing the
discord
the link's all down in there do the
stuff
all right bye